euh transition je vais aller voir euh jean-marc
jankovici et on lui donnera la parole et euh je
pense qu'il va faire le point sur
ce que yap et et le commissaire
henders ont
discuté parce que je vais peut-être le faire se
concentrer sur quelque chose qui est
peut-être  moins du sujet principal de son
bureau
disons parler en public euh sujets
bien que
bien qu'il ait mentionné dans une
conférence du MIT il n'y a pas longtemps, il a fait
référence à un article de ft qui
disait que le nombre très
limité de conseils d'administration de
fortune
1400 entreprises dans  les états-unis pas en europe
n'ont presque pas de références ou
très peu de références
sur le climat et l'énergie, nous nous demandons donc
ce qu'ils font sur leurs
conseils d'administration, donc
je veux que vous répondiez à cette question
combien ils ont besoin de savoir
sur le sujet et je pense que nous  nous avons entendu
certains éléments
et pensez-vous vous-même que les
membres du conseil
sont prêts à être ces acteurs des changements
euh ou à être les acteurs du changement
quel est votre avis là-dessus euh si vous
voulez gagner 10 minutes  la réponse courte
est non
nous avons besoin de plus d'explications tout d'abord je
m'excuse pour mon code vestimentaire il se trouve
que euh
comme vous le savez nous avons beaucoup de bureau
à domicile en france et donc j'ai tendance à être en
tenue décontractée
toute la semaine euh je le ferai  rappelez brièvement d'
où je parle
euh il se trouve que je suis professeur euh oui je
veux dire par tech mais il se trouve aussi que je suis
consultant donc euh
mes suspects habituels je dirais euh sont
précisément des cadres de diverses
sociétés
principalement en france mais parfois à l'étranger
et je  présider une ong qui préconise euh d'
aller bas carbone
euh qui est le projet principal donc je
discute aussi parce qu'il est financé par des
entreprises
euh avec des gens qui sont des dirigeants d'
euh si je résume ce que je vais dire
je vais être  très grossier,
nous sommes loin du niveau de
connaissances
que les cadres devraient avoir, mais je pourrais
étendre cette opinion aux commissaires,
donc je continue à être très grossier, euh et à
euh, je dirais que les décideurs, euh,
dans la commission, fondamentalement nob  ody a
les bases
sur le challenge que l'on essaie
de relever
euh les questions de changement climatique et d'énergie sont
essentiellement des
questions euh relatives à la physique pas à l'
économie
euh quand tu embauches un cadre dans une
entreprise euh
tu attends de cette personne qu'elle ait
suivi de longues études
en gestion apprendre ce que c'est que
traiter avec les
gens traiter avec des chiffres traiter avec de l'argent,
etc. prend quelques années
la durée moyenne de la formation que
toutes ces personnes devraient avoir
sur les questions d'énergie et de changement climatique est
proche
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est entièrement
différent le
changement climatique n'est pas en euros parce
que comme vous le savez probablement la
convention économique fait en sorte que les
ressources les ressources naturelles sont libres par
définition
dans les prix vous n'avez pas de provisions
pour
amortissement dans les prix que vous payez vous
n'avez pas de provisions pour risques vous  n'ont
rien
tous les modèles qui tentent d'évaluer les
dommages causés à l'environnement
en termes monétaires sont tous conventionnels
qu'il est juste  euh c'est proche d'une
recette de cuisine je veux dire c'est exactement la
même
euh toi c'est juste l'opinion que tu
as
donc tu dois apprendre la grammaire tu dois
apprendre les notions
euh tu dois apprendre la physique qui se
rapporte au changement climatique et aux questions énergétiques
et c'est  un long processus j'enseigne 20
heures à mes étudiants
à moyen par tech et c'est loin d'
être suffisant
donc au moins les cadres supérieurs devraient avoir 20
heures au moins
euh mais mais mais c'est un minimum vraiment un
minimum
de ce que j'ai vu euh donc  les gens sont
loin de là où ils devraient être
et euh en plus en ce qui concerne le comportement
ils sont loin non plus parce qu'il
se trouve que dans le monde dans lequel nous vivons
euh l'élément que vous voulez
optimiser en premier
est l'argent et ensuite s'il y a de la place pour l'
optimisation  co2 tu le fais
mais les gens se comportent comme ça parce que
la société est organisée comme ça
tu ne mets pas les gens en prison parce
qu'ils se rencontrent trop mais tu
mets les gens en prison s'ils mentent par
exemple
euh à l'administration fiscale d  on
paye pas ses impôts
euh ou escroc quelqu'un tu ne fais jamais ça
euh pour les gens qui émettent trop de co2 donc
c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui les corporations
parce que c'est ce
qu'on leur demande euh essaient d'optimiser
euh la comptabilité monétaire et puis
encore s'il y a de la place  avec le temps, ils
optimisent les éléments de co2
euh autre chose dont il faut se
rendre compte, c'est qu'il n'est pas possible de
survivre à la transition bas carbone pour
toute entreprise dans laquelle
nous avons travaillé au carbone 4 avec des
centaines de clients
effectuant des milliers de missions euh nous sommes l'
un des  le plus ancien
euh cabinet de conseil en france euh sinon
le plus ancien
spécialisé sur euh les questions de changement climatique
euh nous sommes près de huit ici en ce moment
et euh
nous j'ai vu nulle part euh aucune entreprise
optimisant le co2 d'abord et disant maintenant je vais
prendre  la place qu'il reste à l'
économie
quoi qu'il en soit je n'ai jamais vu ça
et ça n'arrivera jamais tant que les
règles sont ce qu'elles
ne sont jamais et d'accepter euh de renverser
la hiérarchie euh de la voiture les
critères qu'on utilise
que je  s le co2 d'abord et ensuite l'argent
s'il reste de la place
signifie que nous sommes prêts à accepter une
récession structurelle
parce que c'est ce qu'il faut si nous
voulons être sérieux au
sujet de l'objectif de deux degrés
la croissance verte est un conte de fées
je peux répéter que c'est un  conte de fées il
suffit de regarder la physique pour se rendre compte
que ça n'arrivera
jamais jamais euh en fait compter l'
économie en juin
ou en kilowattheures ou la compter en
euros c'est à peu près la même chose
tu regardes la contrepartie que tu peux
compter soit en argent
ou en termes physiques d'un
flux de transformation
qui va des ressources naturelles à tous
les biens et services manufacturés
c'est ce que vous regardez quand vous regardez
le système économique le système productif
et vous pouvez le compter à nouveau en joules en
unités d'énergie ou vous pouvez compter  c'est en
euros la
même chose ou en livres ou en dollars peu
importe la même chose
donc euh et en fait je suis très heureux que
l'agence européenne pour l'environnement ait
publié il y a trois semaines un
document disant que  la croissance verte
n'existe pas
[musique]
donc je regarderai avec beaucoup d'
intérêt un dialogue entre deux
institutions officielles européennes
euh l'agence européenne de l'environnement et
la commission
euh sur ce sujet donc euh
la raison pour laquelle euh donc je reviendrai  à
cela, euh, les conseils d'administration
ont un niveau de connaissances si faible sur les questions d'énergie
et de changement climatique,
c'est parce qu'affronter un monde d'affinité est
quelque chose qu'ils n'aiment pas
parce que dans la théorie économique, il n'y a
pas de limite,
personne n'a dit qu'une fois que le pib atteint je
ne  Je ne sais pas
euh 12 000 milliards de dollars ça arrête de
croître
il n'y a rien de tel dans la
théorie économique mais vous avez plein de
limites absolues en physique
et donc vous pouvez mettre plein de limites dans
l'approvisionnement en combustible fossile par exemple
ou dans le co2 que vous pouvez mettre  dans l'
atmosphère avant
d'avoir un changement climatique qui euh
génère
je dirais des conséquences massives
euh donc c'est très euh
inconfortable
pour ces gens de passer d'un système
où il n'y a pas de limite à  un système
où, fondamentalement, vous ne vous adressez qu'aux limites
, c'est l'une des raisons et
avant d'être félicité
euh par la partie supérieure de notre cerveau,
c'est-à-dire le cortex,
nous sommes commandés par la
partie inférieure de notre cerveau, c'est-à-dire les sentiments,
c'est comme ça que nous sommes  conçu comme des
animaux parce que les êtres humains sont des animaux
euh et je pense que j'ai pris mes 10 minutes
merci merci beaucoup pour
votre pro vos paroles et vos travaux provocateurs
donc en gros les nouveaux énoncés
de mission des entreprises devraient être
de réduire le co2 et non  faire du profit donc
c'est vraiment un changement de paradigme oui
et euh parmi les autres choses que je
pourrais dire j'ai dit aujourd'hui par exemple en
france
vous considérez légitime que l'entreprise
fasse faillite
parce qu'elle n'est pas en mesure de contribuer au
système de santé national euh ou  système de retraite
vous voyez le système que nous avons en
france c'est essentiellement des taxes supplémentaires
sur les salaires
qui paient les pensions et qui paient
le
système de santé  tem et vous pouvez voir que l'
entreprise qui n'est pas en mesure de payer qui
fait faillite c'est légitime d'accord
c'est pas drôle mais c'est une
contrainte collective qu'on accepte
je ne comprends pas pourquoi si le changement climatique
est un problème
si grave vous ne pourriez pas  faire faillite parce que
vous ne pouvez pas relever
le défi du changement climatique il n'y a aucune
raison pour laquelle
je pense que cela ouvrira pas mal de
questions dans la suite alors euh
merci merci pour euh
laissez-moi peut-être encore autour des smes que
euh parfois ils  se sentent comme
euh ils ils ils ne se sentent ni
équipés ni
euh directement concernés ou ils pourraient
euh ne pas jouer le rôle alors parfois
nous perdons le terrain des pme
toute opinion sur ce que le rôle des
pme
les critères pertinents en fait
n'est pas euh
tel n'est pas la taille de l'entreprise
c'est la taille de l'entreprise par rapport
à la taille de l'entreprise
et si vous êtes en position dominante
ou non
euh si vous avez du temps pour de votre côté
euh en gros yo  vous êtes dans une
position plus confortable
euh pour intégrer des défis tels que le
changement climatique
euh si vous êtes un sous-traitant d'un constructeur
automobile
euh en gros euh vous regardez votre
trésorerie
pour les trois prochains mois et c'est
essentiellement tout ce que vous faites donc
euh vous  peut-être si vous êtes un fournisseur
euh employant 5000 personnes euh
un fournisseur de niveau 2 de euh peugeot ou
mercedes
euh ou ce que vous voulez savoir à la fin
de la journée,
c'est si vous l'aurez particulièrement en
ce moment euh
est ce qui se passe  être votre niveau de trésorerie
pour les trois prochains mois si vous êtes
une entreprise d'une centaine de personnes euh
mais vous occupez un créneau dans lequel vous êtes
le leader mondial
vous pouvez regarder 30 ans devant donc euh
plus que la taille encore euh c'est
si vous avez le  le confort
euh de regarder euh des problèmes à long terme
ou pas euh c'est beaucoup plus dépendant de
ta position
dans le secteur et du genre de
relation que tu as avec tes clients
ok une autre question euh
jean-marie si tu me permets qui
concerne le pib pour  Mula,
il y a une question que nous avons dite, pouvons-nous
réorienter la formule du PIB
pour euh développer une sorte de valeur environnementale
euh pour créer euh pour créer un coût dans
l'impact sur l'environnement afin de
convertir la valeur environnementale créée
par l'entreprise
euh pour leur permettre d'effacer le
les pertes économiques
y a-t-il une formule économique qui pourrait
être une
sorte de gain rapide ouais c'est une sorte de
bonne volonté environnementale
d'une manière euh nous pouvons inventer n'importe quoi
euh la bonne question et j'avoue
j'avoue désolé je n'ai pas pensé à celle-
là
euh c'est si c'est non mais je
je ne sais pas si ça va être pour
pousser les entreprises dans le bon sens
euh donc j'ai vu joker je ne sais pas je veux dire
c'est techniquement faisable bien sûr il faut
juste le décider
euh je ne  Je ne sais pas maintenant si c'est une
bonne idée de pousser les entreprises dans la
bonne direction d'
accord une question à natasha euh
les deux dernières questions presque l'une est
pour jean-marc
jankovici et la dernière si vous
me permettez commissaire je le ferai
je vous le donne, euh, personne n'a vraiment
réagi au fait que, euh,
vous avez mentionné que nous devons accepter la
récession structurelle, euh, je ne sais pas si cela
signifie certaines choses, euh, mais les gens
demandent
ce qu'il en est de la société à but,
donc société  dans un but, comment s'emboîtent-ils
et je serais très tenté de poser
exactement la même question au
commissaire
rend euh une autre société à but de réponse
, donc nous plaisantions sur le fait
qu'une entreprise peut avoir le seul but
de réduire le co2 et toujours gagner de l'argent
euh  est-ce un bhoutan ou est-ce quelque chose
qui
pourrait exister et nous aimons croire
que le carbone 4
est une entreprise à but les gens
que nous embauchons sont profondément engagés et l'
une des blagues que je leur raconte quand
ils entrent
est que le carbone 4  l'objectif principal du carbone
4 est de s'auto-dissoudre
parce que le problème sera résolu donc
euh et ensuite les gens pourront écrire
sur leur CV qu'ils ont contribué à
sauver le monde
et je n'ai aucun doute euh qu'ils wi  Je serai
embauché ailleurs euh
avec une très bonne position et au-delà du
carbone quatre
s'il vous plaît dans le reste du monde en tant que
père est mon objectif
mon objectif en tant que père est de dissoudre le
carbone quatre parce que ce ne sera
plus nécessaire
euh je suis  peur que ce ne soit pas pour demain mais
euh c'est mon objectif
euh la comme nous nous sommes une entreprise à but
et encore
euh j'ai un banquier je dois tenir ma
comptabilité
euh et cetera et si on ne fait pas de
profit on finit par faire faillite
euh même si  nous sommes une entreprise à but
donc
euh je ne suis pas sûr que tant que les
règles de la comptabilité
et les règles que nous jouons dans le
monde économique ne changeront pas
cela changera autre chose
que les discussions et les discours euh
tu sais euh l'un des  les blagues aussi que je
fais très souvent
c'est que euh il arrive que euh carbone 4
ait une branche data on travaille pour le
secteur financier
dans le secteur financier il y aurait
beaucoup à dire sur la
sur la taxonomie d'ailleurs mais c'est pas
aujourd'hui euh
sur le mais avec plaisir  je suis un autre jour euh
dans le monde financier euh
je pense que les gens qui ont gagné le
plus d'argent
avec la finance verte sont des gens qui
organisent des événements
où les gens viennent dire que la
finance va devenir verte
euh donc c'est des mots je veux dire c'est mais  quand
vous regardez ce qui se passe
dans le monde réel euh dans les affaires au jour le jour
rien n'a changé euh tellement
si peu euh si peu donc
euh nous devrions être conscients des mots
et regarder les faits c'est l'une des
choses euh
nous  devrait être inclus dans la formation et
lorsque des notions ne sont pas
normatives comme vert responsable
durable quoi que 99 fois sur 100
vous êtes sûr que c'est du green washing donc l'un
des bons moyens de détecter le green
washing
est quand des notions non normatives sont utilisées
c'est ça  pas ça tu ne manques jamais d'accord
donc je pense que jeremiah jankovic le
met très très facilement le
commissaire rend pour que tu répondes
à la même question
euh